[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et un peu moins de 20 ans je faisais du
ski avec mon pote xavier et
machinalement les années qui s'allume
une clope machinalement il lafuma avec
ses gants et machinalement il acheter en
bas et ça m'énervait un point que cette
situation même insurgés je l'engueulé
voire même l'insultait jusqu'au jour où
il me dit un mètre ou moins un cendrier
pour que je puisse mettre ma cigarette
avec mes gonds et je te jure
depuis j'ai eu deux d'un site si tu
acceptes si tu me trouves ce fameux
cendrier ben je ne voterai plus jamais
quoi que ce soit et puis ça c'était
dimanche le jeudi je sors avec des amis
sur lausanne et à la sortie de la gare
on me tend un flyer promotionnelle sous
forme d'une petite boîte toute petite
boîte elle ce flyer
en gros c'était eurêka c'était ma
solution une solution en gros pour
lutter pour que le littering c'est un
outil de changement de comportement
cette petite boîte et depuis ce jour là
xavier est à peu près plus de 3 millions
de personnes en suisse au ras de l'eau
adoptée et ont forcément changé leur
comportement en matière de l'italie vous
savez ce que c'est le littering le
littering à berne
on parle de chute et sauvage chez nous
on me dirait plus communément abandon de
déchets sur la sur la voie publique à
l'époque
donc il ya un peu moins de 15 ans je
faisais des études dans la communication
et puis pour payer ses études
eh ben je me suis retrouvé à enfin vivre
un univers taux plein en montagne grâce
à des petits jobs
s et petits jobs qui m'ont permis de
vivre
effectivement cette saison est de
constater avec effroi avec consternation
le nombre de déchets qui réapparaissait
à la fonte des neiges nos contraintes
ans et je pouvais pas en croire mes yeux
et après avoir étudié on va dire les
différentes ong qui étaient actives dans
la protection de l'environnement
ben j'ai dû à force de me contenter de
constater qu'il y avait aucune entité
qui se battait contre ce phénomène
et donc j'ai décidé de lancer une
nouvelle ong qui qui allait donc partir
un peu aux croisades si on veut bien
pour limiter cette problématique
et puis de là se battre
évidemment contre ses mauvaises
habitudes
et puis pour ce faire dans j'ai lancé
avec vos bagages estudiantin une
première campagne de communication sous
forme de panneaux d'affichage et cette
campagne et ben elle avait un slogan un
peu provocateur jeu là vous c'était ne
balance pas tes déchets juste et
mauvaises habitudes ou même y voir une
double lecture et puis en dessous donc
de ce slogan est bon communiqué les
quatre déchets les plus couramment
retrouver sous les remontées mécaniques
avec leur durée de vie dans
l'environnement si on ne ramassez pas
ses déchets à la fonte des neiges et
puis
grâce à un financement de l'époque est
bon si je suis parti aux croisades avec
vos pâtes à recèle encore un autre avec
qui on a parcouru toute la suisse une
centaine de stations de ski on a posé
deux mille de ces panneaux au départ des
installations aux caisses ou dans les
offices du tourisme dans les files
d'attentes évidemment sur les terrasses
des restaurants est en lice à ce genre
de message ce genre de campagne même si
on peut les lire très vite elle induit
directement un changement de
comportement et puis on va dire une
bonne dizaine de campagnes de
communication plus tard on a décidé de
descendre également jusque sur sur les
lacs
on a on a une participation sur
plusieurs festivals d'été de musique
essentiellement parce que le phénomène
il est il est identique et les gens
quand ils passent leur temps et ils
pratiquent leurs loisirs ils sont
beaucoup plus ouverts et ce sujet un
seul à accepter et à et à recevoir un
message de changement de comportement ce
qui ce qui va nous mener on va dire
finaliser la boucle parce que toutes ces
campagnes ne se suffisent pas
malheureusement donc depuis le début de
cette activité
on mène des opérations de nettoyage
chaque année une bonne une bonne
cinquantaine qui sont qui sont répartis
par toutes sortes d'organismes et qui en
gros se permettent de maintenir
l'environnement au mieux parce qu'il ya
pas des comptes a nié tous les jours qui
vont aller nettoyer nos pâturages ou sur
les pistes de ski et de la de préserver
effectivement notre écosystème et
surtout la qualité de nos eaux parce que
tous ces déchets s'ils sont pas
ramassées arrive trop tard via le
ruissellement dans les rivières et nos
lacs
donc je vous invite tous à vous inscrire
en tout cas pour la saison qui va suivre
au printemps prochain à une belle
organisation pour faire une sortie
nature vous verrez c'est sympa
aller mais surtout à l'est près de chez
vous la faire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]